some positive talk though out of
washington with millions of americans
desperate for help during the pandemic
house speaker nancy pelosi saying
both sides need to get a deal done with
the clock ticking on this congress
listen here
there is momentum there is momentum
with the action that the senators and
house members in a bipartisan way have
taken with them
we'll take the time we need and we must
get it done and we must get it done
by this before we leave let's bring in
white house senior economic adviser
larry kudlow he's out in the north lawn
uh where i typically am larry it's good
to see you there
where is all of this heading with the
coronavirus relief bill and what might
it look like a figure of 908 billion
dollars has been talked about the
democrats coming
down off of their 2.1 uh trillion dollar
uh demand but as we know when you get to
negotiations these things always tend to
creep up
well there's nothing holy about these
top down numbers let me just say that
i'm glad they're closer but as senator
mcconnell has said
he's not ready to sign on to the package
look
i think the individual policies john and
the targeted policies are really counts
i mean i think there should be
additional assistance to small
businesses the ppp
program i think there should be
assistance
for uh unemployment uh that have we've
always
backed that there should be assistance
for states and localities
if it's covet related let's say school
k through 12. those are areas there's
got to be some improvement on the
liability shield
which is important mr mcconnell's talked
about that president trump completely
agrees uh we do certainly
and those things have yet to be
determined so it's not so much the top
down number
now let me make this point you gave the
read-in
on the california uh shutdowns or
restrictions
okay with respect to my friend gavin
newsom and he is a friend
i think that this is a mistake we
believe
and our experts believe we should keep
businesses open
and we should keep schools open and with
respect to the icu
measurement which is not something we've
heard much about
uh our cdc people ambassador debra burks
and so forth
we have teams that can go in and take
care of any issues regarding hospitals
and or equipment we can target those
areas
now i'm not going to say no restrictions
at all any place
but nonetheless we don't want to end
businesses
we don't want to throw more people out
of work it doesn't work by the way
you still have to use the guidelines
okay distancing
and masking and hygiene uh john those
are the way to deal with this
and our team can can uh target it and
look help is on the way we'll be talking
we'll be talking more about
what to do uh with jerome jerome adams
the uh surgeon general coming up but
let's talk about
let's talk quickly vaccine is weeks away
john
the vaccine is weeks away there is a
light at the end of the tunnel there is
a light at the end of the tunnel no
question it's just a matter of how long
is that tunnel real let's talk about the
jobs report 245
000 jobs added unemployment dropped to
6.7 percent
part of the reason it did drop even
though were fewer jobs added
that was expected was because some
people left the workforce
but when you look at this number which
joe biden says is quote
dire is that going to get worse if we
have big states like california shutting
down
well there's a risk of that i can't deny
it
we haven't seen much restraint yet but
there's a risk and i think you're going
to get a spike in the virus
over the holidays but again i think
there are better ways to deal with that
now look
today's number 6.7 unemployment is a
heck of a good number
and people say well it's because
everyone's leaving the labor force that
is not true
if you look inside the household survey
from which that number
6.7 is derived there's something like
480
000 private jobs were added 480
something thousand
private jobs that's very healthy and let
me add all the minority groups
african americans hispanics
asians they had the biggest drop in
unemployment
and women had a huge drop in
unemployment
and if you look at the whole panoply of
information from the economy john
retail sales are strong autos are sale
capital goods durable goods are strong
housing is strong and i've got one for
you this being the holiday season
one of wall street's top economist ed
hyman has a christmas tree survey he
surveys all these christmas tree
companies around the country
and through november that is up 29
year on year so christmas tree purchases
are booming
that's a great indicator it's because
when people are staying home they want
something to brighten up the season
larry we'll we'll see if the economic
numbers do hold but that there do seem
to be signs and i know you're talking to
stuart barney about this this morning
that the economy might be softening a
bit so
we'll see where this goes and how long
that tunnel is jobs are the toughest nut
we've lowered unemployment by more than
half i don't deny
that there's more work to be done and if
we do have targeted assistance
we should help those folks because
there's more hardship i agree with that
but on the whole
indica this is a v-shaped recovery i
stand by that and i think the data show
that
we'll see if you're right when history
tells the ultimate tale larry kudlow
always great to see you thanks for
making it out to the lawn for us